[Music]
in terms of the
bonus that corporate america received
versus the
crumbs that they are giving to workers
to kind of
put the schmooze on is so pathetic it's
so pathetic we also
have in the legislation uh direct
payments which were not in the
republican bill
to america's working families i would
like them
bigger but they are significant
and they will be going out soon
well in 2018 the one thousand dollars
from the trump tax cut were
crumbs by the house speaker obviously in
2020 it's a different
six hundred dollars from direct payments
are said to be significant
but perhaps the biggest quote tonight
that's getting attention from house
speaker pelosi
apparently was said over the past couple
of days this is from
from politico quoting the house speaker
about
getting the president out of the white
house i'm counting down the hours
till he's gone pelosi told her
leadership team as they strategized this
weekend
quote i plan to pull him out of there by
his hair
his little hands and his feet
okay back with the panel uh charlie the
house speaker is uh
he's got kind of a way with words uh and
she's
obviously very happy about the direct
payments this time
yeah exactly you know she's been at this
a long time she's been
been part of the government for a long
time she's been a leader in the
government for a long time
and it's increasingly difficult to take
her very seriously
i do think it's interesting though that
that politicians who try to
to uh to they try to um imitate
president trump and his sort of uh
trumpian language and his way of sort of
uh uh talking about his enemies it
usually doesn't work out very well
especially people who've spent their
entire
lives uh as politicians uh
in political careers and and this new
build that she's so thrilled about
uh it's truly truly remarkable to
consider
uh the degree to which the american
people are held once again as hostages
uh for a bill that that is supposed to
be a life and death sort of situation
uh where they managed to ramp through
billions and billions of dollars of
unrelated things
uh to pay off whoever lobbyists or
whoever you know whatever favorite
interests they're trying to
they're trying to to pay off but but if
if people want
uh want to go back to normal this is
back to normal and nancy pelosi is the
face of it
you know a b you don't have to be
senator rand paul who true to form
fights these things every time
republican or democratic administration
or the six senators who voted against
this
uh omnibus bill to have a real problem
with the process
it is pretty heinous that it gets all
rolled into one thing
and shoved down lawmakers throats in a
matter of hours
5600 pages
right but how many government funding
bills
have you and i watched this very same
process yeah
so it's there is no other process and
both sides are disappointed
the leaders who signed off on this
compromise are trying to sell it to
their own rank and file and their donors
and their voters the american people and
the media as
just you know what we needed to do
but it's a very volatile time house
democrats are still smarting from the
fact that they're down to
the closest margin for a house majority
in 20 years or more
and there's a lot going on internally in
both parties behind closed doors as
they've tried to sort of push out this
deal and hope that president trump signs
it he's now listening to
you know candace owens and charlie kirk
and all these people on the right
online conservatives if you know in
quotes
um who are saying that this is an
abomination and it's a very volatile
time
for mitch mcconnell and and nancy pelosi
and anyone who wants to get this done
with and to move on
uh also with the threat of the veto from
the president for the defense bill
yeah speaking of which uh senator
mcconnell speaking about that
urging directly the president not to
veto
that defense legislation
i hope the president will not veto this
bill
which redoubles our commitment to
modernization
advances cutting cutting-edge
capabilities and equips our military
with the tools and resources they need
to compete with our great power
adversaries
on land on sea in the air and in cyber
space
matthew you think he signs both i'm not
sure he's going to sign the
ndaa uh brett um he's staked out a
pretty
tough position the president has
threatening to veto this bill but
the congress has the votes to override
his veto so it would be kind of
a symbolic gesture on his part um pelosi
though i think it's important to note
that a new poll came out just today with
56 percent of voters saying they would
not like pelosi to return as speaker
they might not get their wish uh in
january but they certainly will in two
years from now
after one last election where
republicans can
across the country can campaign against
nancy pelosi
and quickly they be they do have the
votes on the veto override
right well it's interesting house
minority leader kevin mccarthy
says has indicated he's not interested
in voting against the
uh to override the president's veto and
lindsey graham
the senator is saying that he would
support sustaining the beaches so
i i don't know what will change uh with
with the influence of mitch mcconnell in
the days to come but as i said it's a
volatile time
uh on capitol hill in both parties
a very volatile panel thank you very
much we'll watch it all when we come
back